il y avait un rat dans sa manche 837 le
rat est tombé dans son sac de commission
9h02 leur dit des
prosparis voyez cette séquence
absolument
ahurissante hier soir alors qu'on
interrogeait une femme sur un tout autre
sujet elle s'arrête parce qu'elle
ressent une gêne dans la Manche elle
enlève son manteau il y avait un rat
dans sa manche cette dame sortait du
métro parisien regardez
pour l'instant moi j'ai pas eu de
qu'est-ce que j'ai
un truc qui vous avez une bestiole qui
vous avez une bestiole qui
oh là là là là
il y a une souris dans votre sac madame
non mais j'arrive pas à y croire oh là
là je n'en reviens pas dans votre sac
une souris et si l'impact est plus petit
qu'une pièce de 2 euros nous vous
injectons notre résine spéciale ça part
à Cannes direct prix d'interprétation
Paris
à Paris par exemple Paris de la ville de
Paris à Paris non de Bangkok cette image
que l'on voit pour illustrer Paris vient
de la banque d'image Shutterstock elle a
été prise à Bangkok par un photographe
thaïlandais
52% des Français préfèreraient offrir un
cadeau de Noël à leur animal plutôt qu'à
leurs enfants on s'en fout on s'en fout
pas ça on s'en fout pas
pour participer au débat moi j'offre de
beaux cadeaux tous les ans l'an dernier
non il y a 2 ans j'ai offert à mon
chihuahua qui s'appelle triomphe j'ai
offert une gamelle car le Lagerfel en
cuir
vous voulez la photo après la polémique
la rupture de stock retirez de la vente
par la Fnac après le tweet d'un syndicat
de police le jeu de société antifa est
épuisé rapporte son éditeur victime de
son succès le jeu où il faut animer un
groupe antifasciste fictif et devenu le
cadeau de Noël idéal dans les milieux
d'extrême gauche un effet boomerang bien
connu du web sous le nom des fesses
trésent oui comme Barbra Streisand donc
j'ai offert cette gamelle Lagerfeld
j'offre souvent de très très beaux
cadeaux alors je le rappelle pour nos
cadeaux
il passe avant tous les autres bien sûr
lui il s'en fout et en fait l'an dernier
j'ai eu une révélation vaut mieux offrir
du saumon fumé de la boue plutôt que des
cadeaux
[Musique]
niveau anglais on repassera wedding dans
ces W e un seul e en fait de DNG là où
ils
c'est autre chose alors les deux braises
on va être un petit peu chauvin à la les
couleurs de la France alors on voit
qu'elle a les pattes bleues le plus
moche blanc et la crête rouge bleu blanc
rouge cocorico quand l'animal devient
légal de l'homme et que on inscrit ça
dans la Constitution ça devient un vrai
problème pour pour la vie sereine de
l'humanité enfin tous les débats qui
découvrent de la cause animalis ça part
de là ça part du fait
l'équivalentes
elles sont là pour produire de beauté
j'ai toujours su que la beauté ça
dérangeait et le fait d'être mignon
d'être craquant Gilles on a toujours
voulu pour ça parce que c'est vrai c'est
vrai c'est vrai et ça c'est un truc qui
l'agace c'est vrai
vraiment à merveille en Pascal Anaïs
s'en sort hyper bien quand même
mais vous c'était comment ça ressembler
à des héros du Club Dorothée quoi c'est
ça moi je vous dis un truc moi
ça me dérangeait pas parce que je suis
sacrément bien gaulé donc du coup quand
j'avais ça pour moi c'était normal il y
a d'autres personnes qui regardent
[Rires]
et dire que quand on voit comme ça je
suis très beau je suis très craquant et
j'y vais vénère c'est vrai parce que lui
il arrive ouais moi c'est le succès moi
c'est Astérix et Obélix
c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai
ça fait 26 ans que tu es célib oh merde
je veux bien que tu étais dégoûté ou que
tu sois tombé sur un mauvais coup mais
pour te dégoûter depuis 95 il faut que
Gargamel ou je sais pas quand même
26 ans de célibat mais comment c'est
possible c'est la durée d'un prêt
immobilier enfin en 96 Jacques Chirac
était encore Président on avait même pas
encore gagné la Coupe du Monde et
Kendall Jenner ne marchait pas encore
90 ans aujourd'hui
[Musique]
[Rires]
vous êtes mis dans la bouche tout à
l'heure ça doit sentir très bon et j'ai
envie de fraîcheur une petite galoche
[Applaudissements]
c'est qu'on a l'impression que vous êtes
ici du même moule avec des variations
différentes et vous avez une manière de
vous grimper dessus qui est juste
formidable enfin je dis musicalement
naturellement naturellement
[Applaudissements]